yeah hello everyone my name is Amir
Anika and I'm leading the efforts of
developing the cat boost library today
I'm going to give you a tutorial on
gradient boosting with cat boost now
that is the instruction what you should
download before the tutorial I really
recommend you to download this and to
try everything with your hands it will
it will be yes so I will help you with
everything so it will be pretty easy to
I hope it will be easy to follow so here
are the slides I will here as of the
files that is a link to the slides that
has also the first slide with all the
materials to download what will happen
now I'm going to give you like 10 to 15
minutes overview of what is the library
that I am going to show you and then we
will go through all the practice with
our hands a little use Python for that
and you Peter notebook so it will be
really nice if you would have pieden and
you Peter notebook on your laptop that
you probably do if you are on this
conference so I will show the slide with
download materials one more time
after I'm done explaining for this
campus by the way who of you has ever
used cat paws to serve three people okay
good and who of you has used extra boost
also not everyone so anyway it if you
already have used extreme boost then it
will be super useful for you if you have
not used a cat boost or extra boost and
you will just start with gradient
boosting and you will love it so it will
be useful for you too
let's start cat boost is a gradient
boosting library it's an open source
it's then used gradient boosting library
of the several open source one there is
extra boost like GBM and cat boost and
we are in open source for about two
years now yeah as I told you I will give
you I will tell you a little bit about
cat boost first so I will first give you
some introduction about what is great in
boosting
and then I will show you some benchmarks
how canvas compares to other gradient
boosting libraries so that you know how
to choose and then we will have the
tutorial and then after we finish the
tutorial I'll tell you a little bit
about what we are working now on and
what you will see in the next releases
in close future ok so what is gradient
boosting gradient boosting is a machine
learning algorithm that has several
advantages first of all it works really
well we hit your genius data so there is
homogeneous data like images sound or
text or video and for this type of data
you need to use neural networks and
there is heterogeneous data that is a
table data for example if you are
predicting credit scoring then one
sample will be a person and it will be
described with a set of features like
salary age gender of credit history for
this types of data Radian boosting
usually gives the best solution
and because of that reason gradient
boosting is heavily used in production
of many many companies and it is also
used for machine learning competitions
and you can see on cargo for this table
data most of the competitions are won by
gradient boosting surgeons so it is
super useful to know about the music and
to be able to use it the next thing is
gradient gradient boosting is like very
easy to use as opposed to narrow
networks again you you need to know s
color and interfaces you need to know
how the one function fit one thing that
you need to do though is sometimes you
need to tune the parameter the hyper
parameters but it's pretty easy and the
third thing is that gradient boosting
works really well even if you have
relatively small amounts of data so even
in that case you will have a pretty good
model that you can use later in
production because of these three
reasons gradient boosting is used in
many many places it is used it is used
in industry it is used for
recommendation systems I can tell you
something about how we use it in Yandex
Yandex is a large Russian companies like
a Silicon Valley Russia we have
taxi sir
which adds recommendation systems
self-driving cars personal assistants
all this stuff and most of our products
are using machine learning and most of
them are using gradient boosting so our
research engine our search results are
based on gradient boosting for know our
weather prediction is also based on
gradient boosting formula even
self-driving cars or even machine
translation do use gradient boosting or
our personal assistants this answering
for your request the gradient boosting
is used in several places there to
understand the intent what the person
was meaning and also to to select
between the different versions that are
generated by a neural network so
gradient boosting is are used in many
places in production in our company also
now how does it work radiant boosting is
an iterative algorithm gradient boosting
is usually works with decision trees and
it works as following first we built one
decision tree so that training error has
reduced a little bit then we train one
more decision tree so the training error
reduces even more and then we do it for
hundreds or thousands or even tens of
thousands of times and then we have a
large sample of trees which already can
which helps us have a very low training
error and it also helps us to have a low
validation error so it is important to
understand that gradient boosting is an
iterative algorithm to use it and I'll
show you later
why okay now few things about CAD boost
it is there are there are different
types of data that you can work with
there is numerical data for example
salary is a number and when you are
using decision trees then the tree is
always plating your data in two parts
and if you are using the signatories
it's pretty easy to split in two parts
because you can split the values all the
values where this value is greater than
something and everything else it's not
so easy if you use categorical features
categorical features are features for
with values from
discrete set for example occupation is a
categorical data so you cannot compare
the values of occupation using greater
or less so you need to do something with
categorical data if your patient is a
actually pretty easy categorical data
more complex one would be the one that
has a lot of different values like user
ID for example or so and you you need to
handle it somehow the good thing about
caboose is that it handles categorical
data out of the box so as opposed to
other libraries we do numerical and
categorical features and we do
categorical features really really good
ok now the advantages of CAD boost the
first one is categorical feature support
the next thing and that is something
that our users that is the first on the
list because that is something that our
users usually tell us that that is the
most important thing about the library
and that is that out of the box without
any hyper parameter tuning you already
get a very good result and that is
because we have we are working hard and
having good default parameters they
depend on the data set and we also have
from the start we have a large and
sample so you do not in most of the
cases you do not under fit and also we
use specific kind of trees that helps us
that helps the resulting quality to have
less to be us different when you change
the parameters so that is a really
important thing because you can you do
not have to tune the parameters a lot it
saves you a lot of time and a lot of
machine time also so the next thing is
categorical features the next thing is
that our library contains a lot of stuff
to analyze the model so to understand
why your model is giving you this
predictions those are three very nice
things there is also a lot of other
stuff but I cannot tell you everything
and it's usually good to remember three
things so if you just remember these
three things
about catalyst it will be good okay now
about the quality comparison the usually
when you are trying to figure out which
library you want to use you care about
several things first thing is the
quality and the second thing is a speed
so this slide presents a quality
comparison with other publicly available
libraries like GBM extra boost and h2o
on a set of publicly available datasets
in binary classification mode in on this
datasets can boost always wins in some
cases like an Amazon we win by violet on
others differences so it depends but yep
so there is the whole a bunch of data
sets where that booster wins by a lot
okay that is about ecology the next
thing is about speech and in speech you
care about three things one is training
on CPU another one is training on GPU if
you have GPUs and the third one is
prediction speed and that is if you are
trying to do some applications time
critical applications like we have
searched for example that is pretty much
time critical foundation okay now some
benchmarks about training on CPU on your
ear and prediction the first thing is a
CPU speed currency the state is the
following
on some data sets kept boost is the
fastest on some data sets can boost is
the slowest it depends it depends on
data set on data set properties on large
dense data sets with a lot of data on
large dense data sets with a lot of
features can boost will be the fastest
by far and on small data sets can boost
will be the slowest but we are working
on that right now so I hope it will be
soon we will be the fastest in all the
cases on CPU so here is a comparison on
two data sets Higgs and epsilon and
those are three libraries and here is
the learning time and those are two data
sets so on Hicks can boost is the
fastest one and on epsilon can boost is
fastest one and on Higgs lie GBM is the
fastest one so yeah it all depends on
the data set if you are talking about
CPU speed with GPU speed it's completely
different can boost is by far the
fastest of all the existing libraries
and actually GPU GPUs for gradient
boosting Cal are really useful with GPU
you get a speed-up up to 50 per or if
you are using multi classification can
be a hundred times so GPUs are super
useful and at Yandex almost all our
formulas are trained using GPUs that's
that that's why we are focusing on GPUs
okay here is another useful slide that
you should remember and that is about
GPU trainings the more data you have the
more speed up you will get from GPUs if
you have very small data set there will
be no speed up from GPU but the larger
is the data set the more will be the
speed-up so that is the speed-up that is
the number of samples and those are
different GPUs and with canvas even with
very old GPUs you will get pretty good
speed ups if you are interested you can
try GPUs on google collaboratory and we
even have a tutorial for that and google
collaboratory gives you I'm not sure I
think it's K 80 and you get a speed-up
with that oh okay that's the CPU versus
GPU I strongly recommend you to try
using GPUs for gradient boosting it will
be so much faster okay next thing next
thing is the prediction time and with
prediction time because we we have all
this recommendation systems and all
those time critical applications in
Yandex we care about prediction speed
and CAD boost is faster than other
libraries 30 to 60 times and just now we
have implemented the GPU a player for
our self-driving cars and it's even
faster so if you if you care about speed
it's
good choice okay one more time here is
the tutorial datum please download it
and we will start coding i-i'll give you
three minutes for that if you have not
yet done sir
and if already someone has downloaded
the data and health questions you can
ask yeah yes on GPU on GPU CPU training
is deterministic and GPU training is not
deterministic because you use Atomics
there and the summation order is all the
time different so that results were
slightly different from run to run that
is one of the differences between CPU
and GPU but we use GPUs anyway by the
way who of you is able it has has GPUs
or is able to train on GPUs okay nice
do I need to wait for someone please
raise your hand off if you if I have to
wait for you or everyone has downloads
everything okay okay then we will open
the tutorial we will open the tutorial
to do that you need to run the piece or
notebook command in in the folder where
you have this tutorial and we will start
and tell me if I have to wait for you
just raise your hands and I roll so I
think we can start we will try gradient
boosting using Amazon employee access
challenge data set from Cargill
competition for our experiments this
dataset has the whole set of categorical
features and there is a link to the
challenge you can read about it let's
let's start first we import can boost
and if it doesn't work for for for some
reason it might be if it gives you an
error it might be because you have a
very old numpy if you have a not an old
numpy then it should work the latest
version is 0.15 point 2 but next week we
will have the next version so keep keep
updating and I suggest you to check that
you have the latest version at least
zero point fifteen point one because
some of the things that I have here in
the tutorial there are not present in
all versions okay first what we will do
we will read the data we are reading the
data using the Amazon function from CAD
boost datasets here we have some
datasets for our tutorials and we are
adding new datasets there when we there
is nothing or yeah when we want some
specific functionality and for example
just now we have added there
more datasets with melatonin constraints
because there were no datasets in open
source from a Newtonian constraints so
we have added Yandex internal data sets
this data set is not internal it's it's
external it's from Amazon so we will use
it let's look what is there in this data
set
there are several columns the first
column contains action and the action is
the column that we will be predicting
the data set in this in this task we
want to predict if some person if some
person will be granted with some role
and action one means that the person
will be grant is granted with a row and
zero means that person is not granted
through the roll and we want to predict
that and there is a bunch of features
that describe the person and the row and
everything that we know about this
person for example there the resource
and that is the resource that we asked
access to there is the manager ID it's
the idea of the manager probably that
the Graham Thoreau and some other
features also what we can see in these
features they are all integers but they
look like hashes and they really are
hashes so if we try to use them as
numerical features it will work really
poorly we will have very bad quality
because of that we are handling them as
categorical features and can boost
allows you to do that out-of-the-box so
we have read the data set and we have a
data frame with that what we are going
to do now we are going to build a
training data set and without labels so
just the features features metrics and
we will build a column with labels and
now we will look on the labels so what
we can see here so what what we have
done we first have said that categorical
features are all the features that we
have I will increase this okay I think
so categorical features is all the
illnesses that we have in the metrics so
all the features are categorical and
that is the first thing that we have
done and the next thing that we do we
are analyzing our label values in this
dataset so what we can see in this data
set that this data set has only two
labels zero and one and count of zeros
is much less than count of ones so this
data set is pretty unbalanced and this
will have some convex consequences but
that is just the first thing that we are
doing when we are looking on the dataset
so we have the matrix and at least what
we can do we can look on the on the
balance of the classes and that's it now
we can already train the model so
training the model is really easy what
we have done we have built the x and y x
matrix and Y vector X X is a matrix of
features and Y is a vector of labels and
now what we are doing is we are creating
an object of type Cadmus classifier and
we fit X and wider one thing that is
different from other classifier so that
is actually something that you do with
all the with with all the things in
fighting that really you have there one
thing that is different is that we have
this cat features parameter and in this
parameter you are passing the
categorical feature indices so then the
column is indices where you are saying
that this feature is categorical it is
also allowed to pass categorical feature
names if you want to use strings but we
have indices here one other parameter
that you see here is called verbose and
that controls the output because I were
training for 100 iterations and that
means that we were training in in summer
of 100 trees we didn't want to output
hundred different lines which you will
get by default so we decrease the
velocity okay
so now we already have our first
classifier and what we want to do we
want to make a prediction and to do that
you call the function that is called
predict program and this function
returns you an array where for each
object you have two numbers the first
number is the probability of class being
of the object being class zero and the
the second number is probability of for
the class being one and that yeah that's
basically that's it what you can do what
else you can do to get have good results
you can not use this iterations equals
100 and have the default 1,000 of
iterations because 100 is never enough
but because we are having a tutorial
here and I want everything to run fast
I'm setting the number of iterations to
some small value if you just do this you
will already get a good model for almost
every case in binary classification that
you have if you have table data that is
that that is the first thing that we
have done okay the next thing the next
thing is creating the pool object what
we have done we have used x and y here
that is one choice that you can do and
it's it's pretty useful if you just have
the features and the label but in some
cases you have more things than a
feature on the label for example you
have object weights and in case if you
have an imbalance data sets that that
might be very useful so if you have an
imbalance data set you might you might
add a new column with weights where you
give a large weight for your rare class
and a small weight for your very
frequent class or that is one option or
you might have something else so we have
for our some for some modes we have like
group IDs if you if you do ranking so if
you have a lot of information then you
can create a pool class now so actually
when you are training a model you do not
just want
to fit the function without looking on
the error so here we are just we have
just hit the function and we just look
on the training error usually when you
are doing machine learning what you want
to do you want to use a validation data
set so we have this whole train data set
and now we are going to split it into
two parts one part like 80% we will use
for training and another 20% we will use
for validation so what we are doing here
we are creating two objects of cross
pool one is called training pool another
is called validation pool and yes those
are just two parts of the data now we
will now we will be able to train a
model and to look on the validation
error and to check if the model has and
is under fitted or over fitters so we
will be able to select a good model the
next thing that we want to do is we want
to select the objective function so for
binary classification there are
basically two options log loss and
cross-entropy
and the choice here is the following if
you have the probabilities in your
labels then the use cross-entropy if you
have 0 and 1 in your labels then we use
log loss and that is what we have here
so we are we have selected our loss
function it's basically selected
automatically and if you have
multi-class problem if you have like 5
classes or yeah so if you have more than
2 classes then automatically the loss
function multi class will be selected if
you use the cad boost classifier class
so that is yeah but if you if you have
probabilities then you need to use this
cross entropy error okay now what we
have done we have we have chosen the
loss function we have splitted training
data set into two parts train and
validation and we have fit a fitted the
model with these two data sets with
asseline now let's look a little bit
into what we have in standard output
and to do that we will train our model
one more time
okay so we are tree we are just training
for 15 iterations and it is important to
understand that you should never train
for 15 iterations or four or even 100
iterations and I am saying that because
it really bothers bothers me because I
am sometimes see benchmarks comparing
the libraries where you have ten
iterations or 50 patients and it doesn't
make sense so you better train for
enough iterations and that these 15
traces are just for just for tutorial
purposes so what are we seeing here in
our s3 out the first thing here is
saying that learning rate is some is is
set to 0.5 and that is something that
CAD boost has so if you do not set the
learning rate with your hands then
learning rate is set out for binary
classification learning rate is set
automatically for you using the
properties of the data sets like number
of samples and number of features and
number of iterations that you have in
this case because we have a very small
number of iterations learning rate is
set to a very big number because
otherwise we will under fit we are under
under fitting anyway but yeah and now
what we are seeing here in our log first
we are seeing the values of training
error and of validation error those
things are decreasing all the time so
learning error will decrease all the
time of your training because training
error oldest all the time improves and
the test error or validation error it
decreases while the model improves and
at some point at some point when you
have overfitting it starts increasing
and that means that you should stop here
now here the next thing is called best
and that means that is the value of the
best validation error and the number of
iteration with the best validation error
see if you train for 1000 iteration or
for 5 thousands of iterations it will
than this number
well first increase and then it will
stop increasing it will just have like
reiteration 1150 mems and you train
fuller and it doesn't change now here
you have the time past that is how much
time has passed since you have started
the training yeah and you can see that
you are training for the whole hour
something like that the useful thing
here is a the remaining time so you can
always see in the log how much time you
will have to wait until this finishes so
that is the estimate of how much time
you will have to wait and it's pretty it
works pretty accurate for a gradient
boosting and for CAD boost in particular
so you can look on that now we have we
have trained our model and we have
looked on the validation error on the
time let's do more let's plot something
what we can plot here what what we what
we can plot to put something you need to
pass what equals to true to your feed
function and then you will see the
graphs of all the errors that you want
to look on when we are training binary
classification they up to the optimized
function is log loss but it really
depends on you what you want to work on
sometimes you need to you care about a
you see in many cases because it's a
really awesome metric in some cases you
care about accuracy in some cases you
want to you want to see F 1 metric so
you can you can look on any of these
functions you just mention them here we
have many functions implemented in in
the library and then you can look on the
graph here so there are several graphs
the first one is showing the hollow
gloss improves the dotted line is a
trained air and the not dotted line is a
validation error the point here shows
the iteration with the best a validation
error and it changes you so it plots you
results during the training you can also
look on the a you see here and you can
also look on the curacy here so yeah you
can seek out this matrix change it's
also possible to zoom zoom in it it is
it is nice to zoom in if you want to
look in the detail details in the end so
it is possible to zoom in too to have
the logarithmic scale and all the stuff
okay so that is they're plotting during
the training it is also possible to to
make the plots after the training so
here we'll train two models which are
there which will be very different one
will have a very large learning rate
it's super large you you never should
use this and another one will have a
very small learning rate and they both
will be trained with 100 iterations and
we want to compare them so what we plan
to see here we plan to see that the this
model with a huge learning rate it will
over fit instantly so you it you will
have this best best iteration in the
start and then the error will increase
and the second model with a very small
learning rate
it will under fit so does everyone knows
what is overfitting and underfitting so
okay I think yeah I think it's pretty
much clear and now we will compare these
two models so what we see here we can we
can exclude the the learn graphs and we
will just look on the validation graphs
the green the green line here is the
model that with very large learning rate
with very large learning rate you
instantly get this decrease of the
training of your training and validation
error but you over fits like after 25
iterations and after trying to find
situations this all this this old does
not give you improvement it just it's
just getting worse
worse and the model with very small
learning rate it's in 100 iterations
it's very much under fit so you need
much more iterations so 2 to 4
conversions and actually this line it
will intersect this line and it will be
in the in the end it will be much much
better ok so that is a way to compare
different models yeah
ok the next thing if you can if you look
if you look here as I told you there is
always this best iteration on on the
validation data set on this on this
graph you can see that after 29
iterations you over fit so this this
whole trees after the 29th iteration
they just decreased they just increase
your validation error so what we want to
do we really want if we have over
features if this happens we want to cut
our and samo to the best iteration so we
want to throw away this rest of the
trees and not use them and that is
something that kalpas does by default
and you probably have to know about that
because you train the model and then the
resulting model really usually has less
trees than you actually say it to have
so if you train if you train without
validation it will say you have the
number of trees that you asked for but
if you have the validation data set this
eval set then so we trained here for 100
iterations and we we didn't really over
fit here so I think if we trains a bit
more than maybe we will have it will
reduce more but here you can see that
the best iteration is 96 97 sorry and
you have 98 fees because iteration start
from 0 so we have thrown away to to last
trees but so it is in this case we did
not over fit in the start but they
is important if you overfeed somewhere
like your last five hundred iterations
are trash so what we are doing for you
we are cutting this but in some cases
you don't want to cut it and that
depends really on you if you don't want
to cut it you there is a flag to disable
this behavior okay
that is how we are that that is just the
explanation of what is the example that
you get in the end after you have
trained the model okay the next thing so
we already have trained the model we
have visualized the results we
understand what is exactly the model
that we get that web that we get after
we train the model
now let's discuss a little bit of
different other stuff the first thing
and that we have is called
cross-validation and it's useful too
it's useful for for example to compare
different models
let's training cross-validation here we
will train across a cross validation we
will train a cross validation with five
five folds and yeah we will shuffle the
data and we will look what what happens
here if you I told you I told you in the
start that our data set is pretty
unbalanced so there is this this
negative class is very under represented
now our cross validation can be
stratified and not stratified stratified
cross-validation does the fall so the
regular coalition does the dusts the
following it has the data set it makes
the random shuffle then it partitions
the data set into several faults and
then let's say it's five faults and then
after that we are doing five different
trainings where we have one of these
faults we use for validation and
everything else we use for training
and or we do it five times so the
stratified cross-validation can be used
for question before classification and
it does the following when it does the
splitting into this five fold it ensures
that every class is represented in the
same amount in each of the faults if you
if you do not do stratified
cross-validation and you have a very
unbalanced data set then some of the
faults will have very little amount or
maybe no at all objects of the under
represented class by default cadmus
cross-validation is stratified so by
default we do this and what you can see
here on the graph is the mean error so
its averaged among all the faults among
all the trainings every of the five
trainings has it's just error on every
iteration so what we are doing when we
are plotting this graph we are averaging
the validation errors of all of the five
trainings and we plot a mean here and we
also caught the standard deviation okay
so this graph shows you the cross
validation for stratify for a stratified
version now what we will do we will also
train a cross validation with Nas that
is not stratified and to do that we said
stratified to false okay we will also
see a graph here and you can see that
the the standard deviation is much
bigger so you don't really have to look
on the numbers you can understand this
from the graph that's this this thing is
the standard deviation is larger you can
see that and that is because the
cross-validation was not stratified so
the different test parts they had a very
different amount number of this on the
represented cost yes sir
we also have the
this this points this one and it shows
you the best the best iteration for
cross-validation and that is the way how
you can that is one of the ways how you
can select best iterations best
iteration if you don't want to just use
a validation it's that if you want to
use cross-validation okay
so let's look on what is the result of
the cross-validation the result of the
cross-validation shows you the number of
iterations and on each iteration you
have the thing that we have there in the
graph we have the thematic mean value
for a test and for training and we have
the standard deviation and if you have
if you have mentioned several metrics
here or at least one in the snow then
yeah then there will be the AUC will be
here and on the graph and the AUC will
be here on the in the table also one
thing though with a you see as you can
see here and as we saw I can show you in
the previous graph where we had the AUC
here so we had just one line here it's
just that the test error for AC so there
is no training line for AUC and in
cross-validation you can you can see the
same there is no no column for it for a
you see here and the reason for that is
that a you see is like a super-expensive
metric to calculate so you usually care
exactly about a DC metric but that is
the one metric that requires a sorting
of your whole data set and it's super
expensive to calculate it on every
iteration so we do not calculate it on
train and if you will care about AUC and
if you will want to calculate it and
your training becomes slow for some
reason that that might really happen so
you say at my custom metrics or my
validation metric is AUC and then your
training just slowed down what you can
do you can set metric for
Matta metric period to like to tell or
to some some larger value and then the
metric will be calculated only on every
10th iteration so it will be much faster
yes and that that was about a you see so
you do not have the train a you see here
okay now now let's now I will show you
the next thing so the next thing is
called grid search we do not have yet
our own parameter tuning function in CAD
boost but it will come in the next oil
in the after next release so for now I
am showing you the s color inversion of
prime detuning and I want you to have it
here because parameter tuning is
sometimes important so and you need to
learn how to do this it's really easy
but I want you to have an example of how
to do it here
what does grid search do grid search
runs training with different parameters
and then it selects one set of
parameters where the average validation
error was the best and here is an
example in this example I will only I
will only grid search through a single
parameter that is called learning rate I
will not use other parameters because
because of because I want it to be fast
so you what you are doing you are
writing a grid of parameters here and
then you pass it to the function that is
called grid search CV you train it with
the feed function and then your and then
you get the best estimator so what we
are going to do I here before you have
seen the results we are training for 20
iterations so we are training a very
small ensemble and we are greedy
searching through these three learning
rates what do you think will be the best
learning rate any guess
sorry middle it's that is they're like
super small actually this one is also
small and we are just training for 23
shion's just 20 so I I guess and I hope
it'll be right yeah it's right yes so
the best learning rate is 0.5 and the
reason is the smaller is the learning
rate they're more iterations you need
and the opposite the last iteration you
have the bigger you need the learning
rate so if you have a very small number
of iterations like 20 you need to set
your learning rate to 1 actually to get
to 2 to be able to Train anything even
with this point 5 learning rate the
20-day ensemble's with 20 trees they are
all under filters but yeah that is a
that is the this works together with our
intuition so it it shows it proves our
intuition ok
that is the way how you tune the hyper
parameters you might turn the whole set
of hyper parameters here and I will tell
you about them a bit later ok the next
thing the next thing is called
overfitting detector so we will run our
training with overfitting in detector
now as you can see here we are training
for two hundred iterations so we want to
train an ensemble with 200 trees that's
our goal
but we are saying that we want to stop
training if we see that the training
does not improve already for 23 shion's
if you train for or if you train for
several thousands of iterations then you
probably should say here at least 50 but
yeah so 50 is a good value and if you
train several thousands of
Samuels but here we want to we want to
overfeed with 200 of iterations so I set
it to 20 yeah so and you can see here
that we reach some value and then we do
not improve and the training stops so
there are several choices now how you
can do training one choice is you do not
use overfitting detector you just run
for some number of iterations for
example for the default 1000 and you do
not set the learning rate so you just
believe in the algorithm that the
algorithm gives you gives you a good
learning rate then the algorithm selects
a learning rate based on the number of
iterations that you asked for and it
trains until the end and it will
probably over fit somewhere before the
end so we are trying to make it happen
that is one thing and another thing is
the following
you set the learning rate with your
hands to some small value for example to
0.03 it's also a very good value and
then you that is the default value for
everything that other than binary
classification service it's easy to find
and then you train for many iterations
like for you set it to small value and
then you train it for 10,000 of
iterations and you use the overfitting
detector and it will stop at some point
when you when you see you're hitting so
it depends on you one thing that you
will not get not get here in when you
are using overfitting detector and you
are training for like 50,000 of
iterations and you stop using
overfitting detector after first two
thousand one thing that you do not get
right in this case is the time estimate
of how much longer we will train I have
I have shown you in the standard output
though this last column that shows a
remaining time and it's it's pretty
accurate but only if we do not use our
f15 detector because we really cannot
know in advance when the origin Inc will
happen by the way you can see the same
numbers here so there there is the time
as
one of these things this time estimate
of how much time is left and one in
other is yes so they are the one with
this what this thing is the time
estimate how much time is left and it
changes during the training and another
one is how much time has passed
yes so it depends on you what you want
but basically if if you don't care about
this time estimate you can just use
overfitting in Sector set ten thousands
of iterations of small learning rate and
we'll stop for you okay that was the
overfitting the texture thing yes so
what do you think how many how many
trees you will have there so we have
here the number of iteration is equal to
200 but we didn't train 200 we have
stopped here and that is the best that
is the best iteration the 41 and we
trained 61 trees 62 I think because the
iterations are zero based so how what do
you think what will be the model with
early stop that three-count any guess
yeah yeah exactly yeah is it will be 42
because it zero based yeah that's right
yes so even even if you do early
stopping you still won't throw away all
the iterations that are after your best
iteration okay nice yeah
the next thing so the next thing that I
want to tell you is called Evo metric I
already have shown you the this custom
metric parameter where we are plotting
the whole set of different metrics and
that is just the way that is the way to
look on the metric values it doesn't do
overfitting detector or it doesn't cut
the trees using this method so you
select the best iteration using some
metric and for binary classification it
is log loss and all the metrics all the
other metrics that you have
put into your custom metric field that
we are plotting all those metrics are
not used for early stopping so early
stopping is done using Volvo's but
sometimes if you really want to AB team
to optimize other metric if you really
want to optimize AUC and you want to do
early stopping using a UC you want to do
this cutting of your example using a UC
then you should use the eval metric
parameter so let's train it with eval
metric now the the eval metric is the
first one here and it will be used for
both it will be used for overfitting
detector and this will be used for early
stopping so what we will have here so
the locus has also is also other
pitchers but Lagos is over fitted on the
iteration 41 and a you see on the
iteration 42 so the tree count should be
for the tree count 3 be 43 maybe I have
done something wrong okay so so the eval
metric is used for yeah it's used for
early stopping and for selection of the
best iteration okay okay let's go to
model predictions we now have trained
the we now know everything about
training we know what graphs we can plot
we know how we cut the trees and all the
stuff and now let's do predictions so
for classification for binary is fake
it's a classification there is there are
few ways of doing predictions yes sir so
we will first train another model for
200 of iterations and then we will do
predictions in all the ways that we can
do there are 3 ways of doing predictions
in binary classification using the using
the S coloring interface and
using our interfaces the first one and
that is the one that you should not use
is called predictor
so the predict method gives you gives
you the class value for your object so
the value of the predictor function is
either 0 or 1 and that that is done in
the following way you predict the
probability but you want to decide which
class you will use and if the
probability is greater than 0.5 then it
is you have the 1 here and if it is
smaller than 0.5 then you have the 0
here ok and the 0.5 border is actually
not usually it's not the best solution
for you so sometimes it's better to
select your own border I'll explain this
in in a minute so what you can use you
can use predict proba predict proba is
the second way of making predictions and
it gives you the probabilities for each
object there are two values one is the
first one is probability of being 0 the
second one is probability of being one
and they sum to one okay but so what
gradient boosting does it builds the
trees and then when it is doing
predictions it applies them in a
following way you you have the first
stream you go through all the splits so
this feature greater than one this
feature is greater than 2 and so on you
get to the leaf in the leaf there is a
value a numeric value you get this value
you go to the next tree you do the same
you have the next value then you sum
these two values and then and so on and
then prediction is the sum of all those
values and that that's for for any poor
any mode not only for binary
classification but for binary
classification we want to have we want
to have a value between 0 & 1 the sum of
all the trees cannot be a value between
0 & 1 so in binary classification we are
using the sigmoid to have the to make
the probability out of the sum of the
trees
so really the some of the trees is not a
probability it is not a value between 0
& 1
it's just some real value and then you
calculate sigmoid on top of that let's
let's do this so there is the prediction
type that you call you can pass through
the predict function and this prediction
type is called row formula value and as
you can see and that is just the sum of
the trees for regression test it will be
it will be your answer
but for binary classification is not
your answer you get the sigmoid on top
of that and that's look that looks like
that now why I am telling you this this
is important if this will be important
when we will be trying to analyze the
model so when we will be trying to
understand why the model is having this
particular value and not the other value
let's write our own sigmoid function
it's pretty easy
that is the sigmoid function and let's
now check that the that our that our our
probabilities are sigmoids of the row
formula values okay so we have here row
formula values it's in the in the in the
rope red field we we have calculated
them here now we will calculate a
sigmoid on those values and we will get
some values so let's see that these
values are equal to this this values
okay so let's let's look on the first
object the first object it's the
probability of the sigmoid of the row of
all formal value is the probability of
having class 1 so it should be in the
right column in the predict proper
function okay so it's exactly what you
see here so for the first object it's
point nine seven fourteen okay
so that is how we are doing the binary
classification are there any questions
no okay
no questions good or not good so I don't
know the next thing about binary
classification that you have to know is
how you decide if you want to call this
object positive or negative as I showed
you the the this basic predicts function
here it is just using the point five
border but in some cases you don't
really so in some cases the point five
border is not the best the best choice
so now I'll try to explain you how you
can choose better yes so how you can
choose better if you have your own task
then you what you care about is you
either care about for if when you're
saying that the object is positive or
negative
you either care about false positive
rate or you can care about false
negative rate so in some tasks you don't
want to have any false false negatives
for example let's say I'm a doctor and
I'm using the classifier to make the pre
analysis of for the person and I'm
saying if the person is sick or not and
if the person is if I'm saying the
person is maybe sick then there he will
go to a second exam so what I do not
want to do I do not want to say that the
person is not sick so I do not want to
say that this the person is definitely
healthy if there is any chance that the
person is sick I want him to go or her
to go to a second examination and here I
care about false negative I don't want
to have false negative I don't want to
say that the person is not sick and the
order may be a case where I'd care for
for false positives so what what you
want to do you want to make a decision
what you care about what is a what is a
false positive rate or false negative
rate that is good for you
then you can plot a curve or with false
positive rate or false negative rate
here on this graph I plot both of them
there is the on this graph here is the
probability threshold okay
it's from 0 to 1 and to eat to every to
every threshold there is a point with a
false positive rate or false negative
rate so let's say that I care about
false positive rate the blue one so I
select the error rate that I want on
this graph and then I see what is the
threshold that I want to get okay so you
can look on the graph and select that
but you can also there there is the
select threshold method where there is
this select threshold method where you
just pass the false positive rate or
false negative rate that you are ok to
allow
so in this case for our dataset there
are I'm selecting a threshold for two
different cases the in the first case I
select the threshold where I am saying I
allow no more than 1% of false negatives
and in the second case I am saying that
I'm allowing no more than 1% of false
negatives or or folk of false positives
and as you can see the threshold that I
get for those requirements the
thresholds that I get for those zurk my
environments are really different so the
second one is almost one because for
this problem it's really hard to get
such a false positive rate okay so that
is the way how you if you are doing
binary classification and making a
decision if if you are not ranking the
objects or you if you not not only want
to see which of the objects is more
positive if you want really to make a
decision that this object is positive or
negative then you should you should
select the threshold more smart okay so
now we are able to do predictions for
binary classification the model we are
able to do
predictions for binary classification
let's now see let's now analyze a model
a little bit so the first thing that we
will be doing we will calculate metrics
on a new data set sometimes you have
already you have a model that is already
trained and you have your new data set
like for example for I have the old data
and I train a model on all data and then
I want to check if my new data that I
just that has just arrived how well does
this this model handle this new data to
do this we have this evolve metric
function and yes so you can you can look
on different errors here and as I told
you the yes so one thing is called eval
period and that is on on which on which
iteration you evaluate a metric so if
you calculate metric values and it takes
a long time which you will get with au
symmetric then you can increase this
eval period to some larger value than
one and then you can you can look how
your metric value changes not on every
iteration but on every time situation
but anyway yeah you have you have those
graphs here you have also so the
function returns values of course so it
returns in this case because we were
validate calculating au symmetric so we
call the matrix matrix is the result of
that function we call matrix a UC and
then we can look on the on the various
of this metric on every iteration so
that is the way to see if your model
does still good on the new data okay
it's also possible to pass your own
metric here so you can you can write a
pipe metric or you can write a C++
metric and use it here for for metric
calculation let's go to feature
importances so that we want to
understand
what which features of of my whole of my
whole dataset which features are the
most important ones which features are
the least important ones and maybe maybe
I have some features that I would better
remove so maybe some features are not
good at all there is the whole set of
doing of analyzing feature importances
the first one is called prediction value
change and that that feature importance
shows you how much on average prediction
value changes if there is a change in
this feature this feature importance has
a few very nice properties first one
it's super easy to calculate so it's you
get this values instantly and the next
one is all those values are positive so
they can be normalized and we do
normalize them so they are all from they
all sum to 100 so you can like you can
see a round histogram what is the name
of this and see what is the part of the
importance of this feature into the
whole source
they all sound 100 these feature
importances work really well and we use
them a lot in Yandex but in some cases
like for ranking modes those feature
importances are might be misleading so
they are might be misleading only for
ranking so for for everything else like
for binary classification they work
really well but yeah there is the next
type of importance that I want you to
know and that is called loss function
change so the first one was telling how
much prediction changes if you change
the future and the next one tells you
how much on average your loss function
changes if you are changing a feature
value what we are doing here we are
trying to simulate the following process
we we are training the model with the
feature and then we are training the
model without the feature we do not do
this we approximate this process and we
are saying we are looking on how much
the
lost function value changes if I just
remove this feature and retrain in
reality what we are doing is we are just
removing this feature from all of the
trees and then we are averaging leaf
values and we are saying that this would
be the ensemble that I would get if I
would remove this which one this lost
one or this loss function change this
type of feature importance it works
really well
and for all the modes including for
humans it but it has the disadvantage
that it is time consuming to calculate
so for some need sets especially for
very large datasets it might take some
time to calculate but it's not super
slow so so it you can do that these
feature importance values they might be
positive and they also might be negative
and they are negative
if the feature is not good so if you
would better remove this feature than
the feature is negative here all the
features are important thes are positive
so all of the features are fine but one
thing to about this source function
change importances is you might get a
negative feature importance for some
feature and you will think that it means
that this feature is harmful sometimes
if your model is under features is that
if you train the model for 20 iterations
then some feature is giving you a
negative importance just because without
this feature it would be easier to Train
20 iterations so if you train for more
iterations and if you if you wait for
for overfitting then this feature will
get a positive importance so there are
two to two things that you can think
about when you are see a negative
importance the first one is that maybe
the feature is harmful and the next one
is maybe I'm doing something wrong
maybe my example is under fittest and
then I over feed my example and then I
if it's still negative then it's harmful
I remove it from the model okay those
are two two ways of measuring featuring
Horton's for the whole data set for the
whole model so how much is how important
is this feature for a model but there
might be a different thing that you are
asking and that is if your I am doing
prediction and on this particular object
I have some value of the formula and now
I want to understand for this particular
object why for this particular object
because of which features do I have this
value and for that we have a different
thing that is called shape values
sharply values and shop values of our
calculated per object so each object has
a set of CHOP values and those are one
baseline value that is the same for all
the objects and then there are
importances of all the features all
these importances they sum to the
prediction of the object and that is a
very nice thing about chop values so
your feature importances some two
prediction one thing about binary
classification that I told you is that
the real prediction so the real some of
the trees is not the probability so it's
not a value from 0 to 1 it's some value
from minus infinity to plus infinity so
this for binary classification shop
values are summing to this value 2
through the initial value not to the
sigmoid ok so let's look on some objects
I have selected here two objects one has
a very positive prediction it's almost
one and another has like a less positive
it's it's more and more more like a
negative more and more like negative
object
so let's look on how those things are
explained here first we are looking on
the first object which is super positive
and we are looking how it
explained there is the baseline value
and you can see it here it's it's called
base value and that is the point where
we are starting and that is that is the
point that is the same for all the
objects then we are we are starting from
this base value and we are adding the
importances because of a simplistic
feature I go to the right because of
some other positive feature I go to the
right and so on and I make some steps to
the right then because of some negative
feature I go to the left and so on and I
end up in the prediction of this object
so for this particular object the most
the the the feature with the most
positive influence is called manager ID
the next one with a very large positive
influence is called roll roll up 2 and
so on so you can look on this plot and
understand what are the importance of
different features it is a little bit
tricky with categorical features so with
with numerical features you with
numerical features to those importances
you can not only look on the poor
importances you can also look on the
value of the feature and you can see
that the greater is the feature value
the more positive is the importance or
the opposite and with categorical
features you cannot really do that it
will be like it will be just you have
you have a big positive influence of
manager ID that means that this manager
ID for some reason has a positive
influence and that actually means that
the numerical features that are
calculated inside the algorithm based on
this manager ID feature they give this
positive influence but it doesn't say
anything about the absolute value of
manager ID okay so the next object that
we are looking on is more negative so
there is the this base value that is the
same for all the objects and because we
had this very unbalanced data set this
Bayeux base value is very
to the right from zero okay and yeah so
because of roll code the the roll code
is has the largest negative influence
and yeah you can look on the on on the
importances of all the features here the
visualization is done by the shop
library it does it work does the shop
library work for you
is there anyone having problems with
visualization okay are you having
problems with visualization did you
install a library yes so a shop library
it's a super nice library but at some
point I think they stopped supporting
peyten 2.7 so yeah but the visualization
should work in Python 2.7 and there are
several ways of calculating shop files
you can calculate them using CAD boost
code or you can calculate them using
shepcote because cad boost is also
supported in shop in shop and the shop
part it will not support vitam 2.7 from
starting from subversion so it's more
safe to use CAD boost code and
visualization from chef I here is the
import chap thing and if you have not
heard about this library before I
recommend you to look into this they
have a github repository and they have a
bunch of a bunch of tutorials on
different gradient boosting libraries on
neural network libraries and they have
really nice visualization of model
explanation so I recommend you to look
into this one
okay the next plot that we will see here
the next plot is just showing the
importance of all your data set of all
the features on all your data set they
are ordered by the importance to the
model the most important feature to the
model appears to be manager ID what we
can see on the graph here you can not or
you should not look on the colors in
case if you have categorical features
and that is what we have here
so don't click on the colors just look
on the on the shape and the shape here
the shape here shows the following this
axis is the importance value so it's the
impact of the feature it is negative it
fits on the left from zero and it is
positive if it's on the right from zero
now let's look on the manager ad one dot
shows you one object okay so as you can
see that for many dots manager ad has a
very large negative importance and for
many many other objects manager Heidi
has small positive influence and that is
something that you can see for for every
feature it's it's super interest it it's
super interesting in some cases to look
on this particular graph especially if
you have numerical features with
categorical features the color doesn't
show anything about that's a problem but
yeah if the you still gets useful
information okay that was the that was
the model that were the things about
model explanation we actually do have in
the library much more stuff we have
object importance so you can understand
what are the samples in the training
dataset which are which were the most
important for the last function we have
the model selection thing that is called
eval eval feature so we there is a way
to evaluate if the feature if you should
add this feature to your model and you
will get a statistically significant
improvement so we have a bunch of stuff
there and we will be adding more so the
next in the next few releases we will
add more stuff stay tuned okay
the next thing I want to show you is
necrotic and I really want you to
remember that sometimes when you are
trying to when you are training the
model and you have a large data set and
you are training for thousands of
iterations it might take a while so it
will take for a few hours or maybe it
will take the whole day and if you are
training on your laptop or even on the
server the laptop might go to sleep or
the
my go down or something might happen so
it is a good idea if you have a long
training to use snapshotting it's super
easy you just use the parameter that is
called snapshot file okay I will remove
this first yeah we have started training
we are training training and I stopped
now I stopped there was a keyboard
interrupt and now I will train one more
time and you will see that we train for
100 iterations and we start after the
80th iteration now we are proceeding
from from the point where we have
stopped okay
so if you have a large if you have a
long time training the model use
snapshots it's really almost free it's
saved like everybody fault every 15
minutes I I think so maybe yeah so it's
by default it saved every 15 minutes but
you can set snapshot intervals or
something and I have set it to 1 seconds
because I wanted to show you that it
works but yeah by default it's just
saving every 15 minutes okay now our the
next thing is the saving the model you
can just save the model as a binary and
then you can load it back it's super
easy and yes sir so you you are saving
the model to the file menu can use it in
production the very the our binary
format is a very good format in terms of
how you will application speed say if
you if you will use JSON or you convert
it to C++ code or something else it will
be a bit slower but you can still save
it in any format so that there is a
bunch of things you can save it in is
there is an onyx format formal year I
don't remember so there is a bunch of
formats and I think everything that you
want is covered there okay and there is
a couple of words that I want to spend
on hyper parameters so I will run it and
I will just I will run it for 1000
iterations
I will just tell you about few
parameters that you need to know about
so the one most important parameter that
you care about is learning rate in pairs
or in pair with iterations so what you
want to do you want your model to
overfit a little bit so you do not want
it to to overfit say a lot but you want
it you do not want it to be under fitted
so you want you want to look on this
graph always and see that this best
error is somewhere close to the end okay
if it is not close to the end so if it
is in the end if it is not at the last
point then what you are doing you
increase the number of iterations or you
increase the learning rate better you
increase the number of iterations okay I
am the next thing yeah and and or if you
if it's over if it is somewhere in the
middle then you do the opposite okay so
one thing you can do is you can run with
default number of iterations and you can
and you are not setting the learning
rate then the algorithm sets the rate
for you
and it's somewhere close to the good one
but it's not the best one so if you are
looking on the graph you can use this
graph and use the value that you see in
standard output or in model parameters
this learning rate and then you attach
it a little bit so you even either
increase it a little bit or decrease it
okay the next thing is called depth and
that is the depth of all the tree one
thing you should do you should try depth
10 so you try it the default one six
works well in most cases but in some
cases you need deeper trees well there
is some case where you need two deeper
trees then you try them and if them
works then you can adjust you can try
eight or 12 and if 10 doesn't work then
it probably doesn't make sense to try
those increased values of depth it is
also not a good idea to set the depth to
16 because what we do in canvas by
fault by default we are building full
symmetric binary trees so it is a full
binary tree so if you have the depth 16
then the number of leaves in every tree
will be 2 to the power of 16 which is a
lot so you it's not what you want to do
it's not the same so for example my GBM
the loss the strategy of building 3 is
different so depth 16 doesn't mean there
will be a large launch number of off of
Leafs because it is going not a full
binary tree is growing it's growing not
symmetric tree actually in catalyst you
also can there are several there are
three straight tree growing strategies
that you can use there is the default
one this fool is full binary symmetric
trees but you can also use depth wise
not symmetric tree like extra boost and
you can also use the loss guide like in
light GBM so those three strategies you
can use the second and the third are
implemented only on GPU but we are
currently working on adding them on CPU
also how you can you should select among
them actually the the loss guide
strategy works works well if you have
one hot encoding or if your data is not
noisy so it comes from like the Higgs
data set so it comes from the physical
simulation for example so for data sets
that are come for something from some
simulation and have no or no noise or a
little amount of noise and for one hot
encoding or a super sparse data set it's
good to try the loss guide strategy and
for noisy data sets it's good to have
the the symmetric ones okay and here I
have three more parameters and you can
just play with them you can just tune
them I am let they are staying here in
the tutorial so yeah you can you can
play with them also if you open open the
docs we have a very detailed
documentation on many things including
how to tune the parameters the next book
here is just listing the set of
parameters that you can play with too
to do the speed-up and here is the list
of the parameters that you can do that
you can play with if you if your model
is large for some reasons it if you have
categorical features with a lot of
different values then the model might be
large so if you have this problem then
you play with those parameters okay and
we have we have the our site it's called
caboose dot a I okay I will I will I
will go to the slides
yeah sorry
yes so we have our site it's called CAD
bustier and there is a very detailed
documentation so I recommend you to read
it it tells you everything about
parameter tuning speeding up the
training reducing model size and a lot
of a lot of other stuff also we have our
Twitter account and we have we so we we
have ways to communicate with people who
are using library the library we
actively are chatting with all our users
and we have a set of ways to do that the
Twitter account is basically for posting
news but those two things the telegram
and the slack are for chatting the
telegram account we there is one in
Russian it's called CAD boosted ru and
there is the one in English so if you
have any questions you can ask it in the
chat and they're there there are
different people who are using the
libraries who can discuss it with you
and there there are us we always are
reading that and answering and the next
thing is the slack Channel I there is
the district community is it's mostly
russian-speaking but it's like the
largest data science community in slack
and I'm sure anywhere is there is a
larger community it's about 30k people
there is the communities are called ODS
and there is a bunch of channels in
there and we also have a channel our
channel in there it's the channel is
called toolkit boost and so people are
asking questions there are a lot of
Russian questions but if you ask
something in English you will definitely
get an answer from us and from other
people also yeah the the slides there is
yeah there is a link of over the slides
and now I will also tell you if you
words about what we are working on we
are currently adding text features and
embeddings as input data types which
would will be super nice because it will
work our out-of-the-box with text
together with numerical features we are
adding sparse data support it will come
in the release after the next one and we
are adding new
methods for model analysis more metrics
and training speed ups and I have like
five minutes for questions okay
yeah yeah so what we are doing with
categorical features is we are
calculating different numerical features
on top of them if you have a high
cardinality categorical feature or any
other categorical feature we are
calculating statistics that are similar
to target encoding but they are based on
some random permutation so if you have
binary classification then you're a new
feature value that is based on
categorical value value will be the
average label value given this category
value but this if you do it like that
then it doesn't work so what we are
doing we are doing a random permutation
on the data and then we are using only
the object before this one in the
permutation to calculate those averages
and we are using we we are using also
some several priors in this formula and
we are calculating statistics based on
categorical feature combinations and we
use one part encoding for features with
a small number of values yes so there is
a parameter that is called one foot max
eyes and you just set this one for lower
you have on what encoding for greater
you know have statistics if you have
anything that you want from the library
you are also you can ask me to add this
and we will probably add this at some
point
you